[Musique]
bonjour thomas ça va oui et vous bas
j'ai fait un rêve complètement absurde
j'ai rêvé que mon réveil sonnait c'est
complètement couillon parce qu'après
vous vous rendormir au réveil a déjà
sonné complètement décalé ville c'est
pas grave à faut faire avec
[Rires]
bonjour bonjour
mais que s'il ya
bien un truc jaune et
je me casse se fout de ma gueule allez
on est sympa on ne sera pas se moquer
et puis notez encore que c'est françois
hollande royal qui sera l'invitée
la limitation ne
trompent pas quand tu fais qui coûtera
peut pas autre chose qui fasse un quick
voilà c'est très insuffisant
musicalement mais c'était tellement
mauvais on dirait des français il vit en
italie près de rome il a 30 ans il a été
condamné dans une affaire de trafic de
drogue sa peine avait été aménagé un
sous forme d'assignations à résidence en
clair au lieu d'aller en prison il
devait rester 24 heures sur 24 à la
maison seulement à la maison et aussi sa
femme pas toujours facile à la vie de
couple quotidien et c'est ainsi qu'au
bout de quelques semaines notre homme a
fini par craquer il s'est présenté mais
prise raza commissariat exactement en
expliquant qu'ils n'en pouvaient plus
d'être à la maison avec son épouse qu'il
préférait dormir en prison alors le
capitaine des carabiniers a simplement
expliqué que n'étant pas chez lui
l'individu a été arrêté pour violation
de son assignation à résidence et
transféré en prison comme il le voulait
merci vous êtes bien belle histoire
mathieu camp qui nourrissent remercie
ses cascadeurs il ne fait pas semblant
l'acteur a offert une rolex à quatre
membres de son équipe sur le tournage de
john wood 4 de passage à paris c'est le
meilleur cadeau qu'on lui a fait déclare
l'un d'eux sur instagram peut être
également le plus cher comptez minimum
7000 euros pour ce modèle
[Musique]
ah ah
sur internet la réputation de keanu
reeves ce n'est plus à faire il est
proche de son public
un chic type qui met un point d'honneur
à garder ses distances avec les femmes
qui demande une photo avec lui vous avez
mal aux pieds parce que vous avez marché
de mes rêves toute la nuit
technique de drague c'est un cadeau 25
qui d'autre en kilos c'est ridicule
c'est même pas le poids dans deux
médecins
locaux vides serait bon pour la santé
sexuelle ou plutôt la peur tu covin oui
tout à fait exact c'est en tout cas le
résultat d'une affaire de la marque
qualitative menée par les psychologues
de l'université de lisbonne en
partenariat avec l'institut kinsey aux
états unis les rapports sexuels de 303
couples ont été scrutés
consciencieusement par les scientifiques
depuis 2020 à la loupe alors c'est un
fait divers pour le moins étrange qui a
eu lieu hier soir en plein bois de
boulogne l'agression du milieu de
terrain du psg ander herrera par une
prostituée le footballeur a affirmé à la
police quand travestissent est introduit
dans son véhicule à son insu s'est
installé à la place du passager a mis la
main sur ses effets personnels non
patrick je parle des portables et du
portefeuille dans lequel se trouvaient
deux cents euros en liquide les deux
protagonistes ont fait un bout de chemin
ensemble le footballeur aurait alors
insisté pour récupérer son portable
quitte à perdre ses 200 euros cyril est
ce que vous êtes déjà allé au bois de
boulogne pour
décroiser
et pour aller courir n'y a pas que
j'allais moi j'y vais très très très
très très régulièrement pour voilà pour
me balader pour courir pour faire du
vélo et pour la nourrir alors si vous
avez croisé géologue à la pompe est
resté sur le vélo il ya rien
en fait les plus inquiets d'entre nous
sont aussi su ce sont aussi suspendues
tout ce sont eux aussi amélioré à ne
plus faire aussi alors qu'est ce qui a
trait aux égouts
mais laissez moi tranquille il serait le
plus osé qu'est-ce qu'ils ont osé ces
gens-là ébats des nouvelles pratiques
peuvent le sexto c'est que c'est l'envoi
de textos un peu savamment rempli démoli
fruitiers
les selphy causerait un accident mortel
chaque semaine dans le monde oui et
c'est pas drôle ça s'accélère depuis
2008 dans le monde au moins 3 179
amateurs d'autoportraits sont décédés ça
fait 1 tous les 13 jours et le phénomène
s'accélère un par semaine en 2000 à 21
sont donc décidés est décédé en voulant
se tirer le portrait
mais la lave et ça passe
[Musique]
l'étude rapporte que c'est l'inde qui
est loin devant premières places de ce
triste palmarès avec 100 morts depuis
2008 des chiffres qui s'expliquent en
partie dit la fondation par le fait que
beaucoup de personnes prennent des
selles fille là bas voilà ça les deux
celle ci je vous la montre parce que ce
couple s'en est sorti sans de bobo grave
vous voulez bien fermer les yeux 30
secondes je vous emmène dans la jungle
du rwanda allez-y
[Musique]
je peux parler dans la forêt tout seul
parce que ça reste quand même dangereux
et avoir des animaux sauvages tout ça là
mais le pire c'est si tu tombes sur une
tribu cannibale pas parce que les
animaux
non mais s'il existe on voit ce pas les
animaux qui me ferait peur serait plutôt
les cannibales de la junte quoi je veux
dire j'ai pas envie de finir ont foulé
retient allez les gars première question
combien de temps elle est malade il
julien
[Applaudissements]
24 mois de réponse alors eva 26 bat
réponse si on a tous des facettes mais
pas de l'être humain enfin pas d'un
crocodile ont même il va elle était
assistante dentaire
[Musique]
jennifer vous êtes sûr que vous ne
voulez pas goûter un peu de poisson
tiens non non et loin de moi cette a
fait cette odeur dans l'alsace assez de
leur sens assez pour six personnes
bonjour je suis désolé ça sent la piste
qui pensent à
habile jeu franck qui pillent déjà déjà
miné d'antoine et je vais manger comment
tu peux te permettre ces centres pipi
on va bien cinq dossiers de marion a
investi dans un poêle à 5000 euros et
malheureusement le poil ne fonctionne
pas il a même failli mettre le feu à la
maison et doha 5000 euros le poil
l'épilation ça doit l'écouter petit
reporter moi ça me rappelait un meeting
avec les producteurs de cette émission
pleine mauvaise idée à la fin tu as
l'impression te ferme